welcome back to New Rockstar and the new
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania has got us all excited to head
back to the quantum realm to see the
sights some new faces and a couple of
big old faces like the big bad Modoc
with his little dangly legs working with
Kang the conquer what if I told you that
monoch had a secret plan to betray his
new co-worker what if I told you that
Modoc was planning on raising an army of
evil Modoc variants to take over the
Multiverse this is Rogue very the show
where we picked the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we love a show
made possible by the lovely people over
at Noah VPN more on them later my name
is mte going along with me today is the
wonderfully amazing the realest of us
all Jessica Clements what's going on hi
uh I know that we're sponsored by a lot
of big hats but what about big bonnets I
know that I'm the only one that wears a
silk Bonnet
um and the only other POC here is bald
but maybe everyone can wear it hear me
out it's good for all you know I'm about
to wear a body in solidarity
what's going on Matt hey happy New Year
everyone happy to be back to talk about
some uh Modoc and kids so it's gonna be
a fun one for sure it's gonna be so good
and our wonderful my brother my the main
man himself Brandon Barrett what's going
on Brandon oh hello I'm TV Mt so good to
see you again so glad to be back on
Rogue Theory I I am ready to get very
Rogue I'm I'm this time new year new
rogue new yeah dude quantumania is
looking like the most roguest Marvel
movie that we've ever seen because like
that whole trailer was just like where
are we what is going on this is like the
craziest like the weirdest visuals I've
ever seen in the MCU which leads us to
our first topic of today Modoc the
weirdest looking man in the world
um he's he's in the MCU and he's back
and he's working with King the Conqueror
I think that he's up to something I
think that Modoc could be secretly
planning on building an army of modocs
to take over the entire shindig to take
over Kang's operation he's gonna be like
oh yeah King you can set it up while I
uh I'm gonna take it at the very end and
like take your army and go go wreck shop
but uh you know we saw on the trailer
that Scott was able to duplicate himself
we don't know how that's possible but
it's like one of the weirdest and most
staggering things in the trailer
um and I think that you know Modoc could
be using this technology to replicate
himself because like Modoc thinks that
he's the smartest being in the world
um he's he's so arrogant in the comics
and um he he likes to work with like a
large group of people with aim but like
I feel like maybe since that this is
Darren cross and like he has a really I
don't know people screwed him over in
the past I think that he's like you know
what I don't want to work with other
people I want to work with me because I
could only trust me so I'm gonna make
all these variants gonna duplicate
myself like Scott and then we're gonna
go and take over the Multiverse what do
you guys think about this I think that's
a very fair uh uh Shake you're given to
Darren Cross by being like people
screwed me over in the past
what about
that pretty screwed over I would say
it's true he killed Frank
him and made him into a like weird pasty
rest blood and then threw them in the
toilet it's terrible don't I guess from
Darren's perspective he does feel
screwed over right he feels screwed over
by Hank Pym he lives in Hank pimp no can
never go out of it he wouldn't get the
secret the secret tips it seems like
yeah Darren cross got shrunk down as
yellow jacket he got sucked into the
quantum realm Kang finds him uh like a
little baby Voldemort
uh covered in goo and it's like I'll fix
you buddy I'll fix you and he just fixes
his head and gives him well I guess
because it was hard to tell the scale
from the trailer but I think he has
normal human arms and legs it's just his
head is so giant right yeah is that what
happened or what if he has like a normal
like human-sized head in the quantum
rooms just got small that'd be hilarious
perspective I could definitely see him
using this whatever duplication
technology to make all the like aim
soldiers right they're the ones that
were like the yellow hazmat suits right
do they have like a fancy name or they
just like aim a generic name
I don't know henchman there is a name
for them and I'm blanking on it
but there is a name for that man that's
gonna drive me crazy is it though the
beekeepers it's like beekeepers right
yeah something like that something yeah
like the beekeepers so like maybe
they're just the beekeepers we're not
confusing this with the Venture Brothers
I confuse everything with Adventure
Brothers the Doctor Who Star Trek I just
confuse it with Adventure Brothers just
kidding but no like no for sure like I
think that
um Darren cross is just very cross he's
very cross at the the at Scott Lang and
um but just everyone he just doesn't
trust people because like he had this
whole company he had it all he's about
to make millions of dollars selling um
this Tech to Hydra and then he got
freaking screwed over after fighting
Thomas the Tank Engine
um in a little girl's room and yeah
and he's like he's just like you know
what I need to do these things right my
way I am the mental organism designed
for computing I'm gonna go kill some
people now
yeah I think that it's possible here and
above video sorry is it did you guys did
you really enhance that is that really
Darren crosses like a shot of him in the
background uh when they're walking
through the portal you can see his like
little face like his head is just like
hey and it's like Bob had peeking out
over the top okay cool that's great
that's freaking great I'm surprised that
they even revealed that in the trailer
because like that that seemed like a
surprise that'd be in the movie but
they're like you know what whatever
people know how to talk about I really
do think that Brandon is on to something
here I do think that like that's pretty
spot on but I'm a little a little more
Rogue with a little more Rogue on this
one uh I I think because I kind of feel
like Kang is too smart and Modoc even
though he's like you know he's kind of
he's a smart creature uh right he but he
he's kind of dumb in his way he's like
and I don't think Kang would make
someone who's like dumb you know so I
kind of think maybe it is a Darren cross
and an alternate in a Multiverse who got
into you know who was tan who was
working who was at the in that
Multiverse was running aim because aim
is like who created Modoc and they they
turned him into he tapped into he
figured out in this Multiverse that's
how we can get into the quantum realm
was like by using them like you know
putting him his mind into this mental
organism designed only for killing or
maybe they called in something else with
a K but but like that's how Eagle's able
to tap in and it's actually he's like
you know he's trapped there from a
different Multiverse uh and he's gonna
him and like he's trying to offer King
like the ability to like use the
equivalent of pin particles you know uh
in turn uh he's gonna try and backstab
King and try and get access to like his
time abilities that's right like his
time his ability to access like whatever
time however Kang is able to control
time in this universe uh he's gonna want
that power so I think it's like I think
it's from a Multiverse I think he's like
he you know he's coming in uh to
basically try and double cross Kang just
like Brandon said but uh I think it's a
Multiverse uh Modoc person
because I like that idea because if you
think about it like Darren cross lost in
Ant-Man one an infinite amount of times
in the Multiverse so like there's an
infinite amount of variants that gets
shrunk into the quantum realm so like
technically we could have like a whole
Army he could find like barbarians of
himself be like all right guys let's
let's all work together and yeah I like
that it's a lot I would love it too
thanks I would love it if like if
they're to even aim like grunts in this
world like he brought his like little
army he's like oh yes aim modak with
control of the quantum realm with my
minions you know like I want that mode
like I want to go full like super ham
like I want that you know the idea of
like a multiversal variant because like
this could be a Darren cross who did win
in his Universe right yeah like he
figured it out and he figured out the
pen particle and like he sold it to
Hydra and he was very successful and
then like his hubris got him stuck where
he's like oh I wanted to I figured out
the pimp article next for me was the
quantum realm and he did it but then he
got stuck down there as a big head with
with normal arms and like exactly yeah I
just feel like aim isn't done yet
because in our MCU in our universe aim
was run by Aldritch Killian from you
know Iron Man 3 and that was already
thored but I don't think that's the last
we've seen of him you know I I think
like I think that's how we reintroduce
them is that that's how MO Modoc is
running in a Multiverse because in the
comics modux running aim and that's how
we reintroduce the like beehive kind of
main aim that we know you know I like
that theory because then it also gives
way to even if it was an illusion how we
saw the beekeeper in one division
um
yesterday that I was like oh I think
we're gonna see Wanda again uh in the
quantum realm and so I'm like give me
any reason that she could do anything
that affects the quantum realm so I
agree with Matt I know this is mt's
Rogue Theory but I don't know like I I
definitely agree that like there's going
something going to happen where Modoc is
going to eventually be in charge of aim
um he's going to take over Killian's
role I'm just gonna escape the quantum
realm he's gonna be like all right one
of those aim this is great beehives I
love B Sky loved me so much
eats a bunch of bees oh it's disgusting
but no going back to what you said about
um Modoc wanting to control time if you
think about it Modoc is a freak either
freaky looking man he's not supposed to
look like that so maybe he wants to go
back in time and change like his
transformation and go back to being a
normal looking man who knows even though
time travel doesn't work yeah exactly
like that in the MCU maybe he's gonna
try who knows he's like I just want to
beat it I just wanted to go on a dance
no one wants to swipe right in my gender
profile I'm disgusting
look at me I looked genius but I'm a
monster
maybe this modak is from a universe
where that's how people look he's a
normal looking dude
like you're all are the freaks all right
he's like why are your guys's legs
smaller than your head it seems weird
that you guys can walk and not fall over
every time you touch the ground right
I do I get excited about aim coming back
I really hope it happens because then we
can get a Marvel special uh about uh Bob
agent of aim which is like there's a one
shot There's a comic I might be
misquoting that but it is a One-Shot
comic that they did and I would love it
if like Bob Odenkirk was like an agent
of aim and like it's just a day in the
life as a grunt that's it's a single
issue comic that came out like probably
like eight years ago but it's fantastic
yeah and I want to see them the same
agent of hydro Bob it's a different one
no so it's not Bob it's it's like it's
just an agent of eight okay if I it's
like I forgot the name that they gave
them but it was just like a grunt it was
like the day in the library dude like a
good like random like all right I'm a
grunt story I think a Marvel Studios
needs to do that like we need like a a
weird like henchman grunt story
um maybe like like frog man like
leapfrog is like hey just take a grunt
and we see the day of the life of a
grunt but no Jess tell me more of your
thoughts of this Theory like we want to
hear some the real the Rogue queen Jess
I like it
okay
end of sentence that's all I need I like
it
I want more in regard I I he I get like
kind of Revenge but also being like I'm
smarter than
um all of them and like just hating
Scott Lang because of it
I guess I just want more than that
because like how long have we not seen
him right and then the blip happened and
all this stuff happened and it's like oh
you haven't changed your motive
um that's and I think it's why Matt's
Theory got to me because I was like oh I
love the idea that this is a different
yeah like what if like we somehow see
like the the Modoc from the comics like
what if they bring like the actual Modoc
via the Multiverse to work with Darren
cross to be like it's me real Modoc
because you know why not
number one from the 2D Comics uh I think
that'd be really fun yeah or bring in
the Patton Oswald there's a Clayton
engine scene that he's like he comes in
oh my God yes is he weird have like a
cartoon or the clay Mansion Modoc but
only Darren cross can see it it's like
his like is crazy
more evil and Darren cross is like I
don't know I'm trying to if you think
about it like in the first Ant-Man movie
he got progressively more and more
crazier like the Bim stuff made him more
crazy so that's possible yeah do or do
you like the scene from the boys where
like Darren cross is talking in the
mirror
on the other side of the player is the
2D cartoon Mo dog he's like you can be
better
if it is like every time I talk to you
you look and sound worse I don't want to
become you
who was there for you when you got
shrunken down to the quantum Realm
no matter what we just want him to
commit to that voice man that's just
great and Corey still does a good voice
as Moda yes yes oh I do have a
correction it is it was Hydra it was
it's Hank Johnson Hank Johnson agent of
Hydra that's that was the one shot I was
thinking of but still yeah because
that's I mean hydra's kind of gone right
now
cut off one head two more go to take its
place and one of those heads is uh Bob
or Hank the Agents of Hydra but no let's
let's vote on this Theory you guys think
of this Theory as rogus bogus or ogis
take it away Jessica I'm gonna still
give it a rogus because I think which I
say every Rogue Theory we start
forgetting what Rogue theory is about
it's about being wrong I think it's a
rogue idea and I think tangentially it's
still connected to when we last saw him
in the first movie so I think I hear it
I understand it do I want it no but I
think it's a good recipe do I want it
absolutely not but I think it's a good
Rogue Theory nonetheless okay thank you
Jessica what do you think Matt I think
it is a rogueist because this is still
an Ant-Man movie
and every rogus has a little stipulation
but
all right what do you think about this
Brandon okay I mean I'll go with the
crowd I'll give it a rogus but here's
what I'll say Darren cross may want to
do this he will not succeed at all Kings
Kings all over it King oh yeah King will
shut it down completely yeah and I want
to give a side rogus to Matt's theory
that this is not yeah I love that this
is a new Darren cross that's a good
twist and I like that I like that I
would yes I will also I'm gonna give you
a double roguez for that one that was an
ad that was a really good one I love
that one I want Hank Pym to be like
you're you're Darren cross and hang and
Darren cross be like I have no idea I
don't know
or if you
'd for hang him in a different timeline
but not he doesn't know who Scott is
Scott never was there so he's just like
who's yeah exactly who's you whose man
is this man is this take him away
all right guys this is really fun but up
next Jess is going to hit us up with her
own amazing Rogue topic but guys be sure
to check out new roxasmirch.com where
you can grab some awesome new new
rockstars gear and it's not just shirts
we got hoodies hats stickers enamel pins
and so so much more so support the
channel and check out all of our awesome
merch options over at New
rockstarsbirch.com we also want to thank
our amazing new partners over at nordvpn
because have you ever gotten extremely
hyped to watch a new series or film only
to discover it's not available for
streaming in your country it hurts it
hurts my soul every time it happens well
nordvpn has recovered with Norm VPN you
can switch your virtual location on your
device with just one click giving you
the ability to access streaming services
from over 60 countries at no extra cost
and it opens up a Quantum realm full of
entertaining content which you wouldn't
be able to access without nordvpn and
with over 5400 servers in 60 countries
nordvpn gives you access to games and
streaming platforms that are currently
not available in your region and the
best part is nordvpn will not slow down
your online experience that is very
important we know that you guys like
fast internet experiences norvpn does
not get in the way of that they've done
the speed test and nordvpn is the
fastest VPN out there and they even keep
you safe from hackers malicious sites
and pop-ups while browsing the internet
all with just one click so grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com Rogue Theory and you will
get a huge discount off your newer VPN
plan plus a bonus gift it's completely
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee that's nordvpn.com Rogue
Theory we also want to thank bespoke
Post for sponsoring this podcast because
every month has one day that is more
awesome than all the rest and that's
today that your box of awesome arrives
from bespoke every box of Awesome from
bespoke post contains incredible items
that will make your kitchen wardrobe or
even the outdoors more awesome that's
really one of the coolest things about
bespoke post every unique item is hand
curated from a small business that you
probably wouldn't have never heard of
otherwise from cozy Essentials to travel
must-haves and cocktail kits box of
awesome has everything you need this
month so to get started take the quiz at
box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you and they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 dollars but you only pay a fraction
of that price plus with each box of
awesome you're supporting small
businesses ninety percent of everything
that comes in your box of awesome is
from a small up and coming brand which
is really cool so it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month or cancel at
any time get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code Rogue at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
Rogue for twenty percent off your first
box box of awesome.com code Road and we
also want to thank battling blades you
guys like swords get ready for this one
because if you've had to take on Kang in
the quantum realm you'd probably want at
least a sword to fight with am I right
you've got to impale somebody uh even if
you're not taking on King the Conqueror
you probably still want a sword so why
not check out battling blades just you
know wielding responsibly please
um
badly Blaze designs and sells high
quality swords axes machetes and knives
striving to design and create products
with the highest quality Metals bone
wood and leather and it's more than just
blaze battling blades also sells armor
Shields and helmets to really get into
character get you that whole setup baby
so looking for something a little bit
more personal battling blades will take
your custom order to make the blade of
your dreams seriously check out their
incredible sight and see everything that
they have to offer we got their high
carbon Damascus steel Bastard Sword in
the office and it is awesome like it is
super cool I can't believe we have a
sword in the office my God it was
horrible idea it's a horrible idea oh
someone's gonna get killed It's Gonna be
Me
So for 20 off your badly Blaze order go
to badleaguebades.com enter code Rogue
at checkout that is
b-a-t-t-l-i-n-gblades.com and enter code
Rogue at checkout to get 20 off your
order we think battling blades for
sponsoring this video alright Jessica
Clemens the wonderful and amazing
roguest queen that we have in this
office is going to take us away with
topic number two Take it Away Jessica
thank you Mt my topic why I look like
the brown Eminem So
you do know
I have a presentation to give you
my rogue theory is a very Rogue very
unrealistic but if you use your
imagination it could be realistic I
think Cassie Lang's gonna die in this
movie so
MCU and I was like I don't try to kill
people I just need justifications and
they need to die so
also yes like Brandon said she's old
enough she's 18. yeah
okay okay she also was in blips so she's
probably like 22. either way
a lot of deaths but um I essentially
think we we need
someone as big as Cassie Lang did that
it has to be cashier it has to be helped
but we're seeing a lot of Hope and I
agree with Brandon who I don't know if
he's mentioned it online but offline he
has mentioned seeing them in costume in
the quantum realm but getting sucked
into the quantum realm like it was a
normal Sunday afternoon right they go
into the quantum Realm by hat like by
accident completely they're in their
normal Garb so how are they in their
suits right so I think they get out and
then they come back in and I think a
reason they get out and come back in is
when Kang says I can make a deal with
you I can give you more time it's
because as soon as they ran into Kang
Kang takes Cassie and kills her and I
think that's where I think he kills her
I would love to say he locks her up
genuinely if Marvel Studios wants to say
like hey we can't kill her they lock her
up but I do want her to die I think she
dies that way Scott's like I have to do
this I need to get my daughter back and
Janet's like you don't understand that
man is a literal crazy person he made
he's a sneaky Fox and he's like yeah but
you have your daughter and you have your
husband I don't have my daughter any
more that's all I had so I need that
time so he goes through the quantum
realm doing what Kang needs him to do
and when he does it they Supply it by
get bringing Cassie Lang back but when
he brings Cassie Lane back he sends her
out like she's like I think it's because
when he's reversing time or doing
whatever she essentially wouldn't have
been in the quantum room yet she'd still
be outside so she's outside and that's
when she comes back into the quantum
realm later in her suit ready to go and
fight but I think she has to die she
gets resurrected comes back in and Hank
is stuck in or Scott Lang is stuck in
there and that's them trying to get
Scott out
bananas like that would be like massive
massive massive like a huge surprise for
everyone in the theater and like it but
it makes sense considering that we are
you know in this you know Multiverse
stage of the MCU we know that variants
are a huge thing and then like they can
they can essentially be I mean if they
have the same memories a good
replacement for someone who dies I mean
I would say that's a good replacement so
like yeah I think that this would be a
really good carrot to dangle from the
sky and be like hey I killed your
daughter but don't worry you have an
infinite amount of daughters I can save
her uh we just you just gotta do
something for me I like that do you
think that what like the kind of the
reason for King to do this is that they
need some sort of he wants to like the
tech or yeah some pin particle thing or
something that they that he needs in
order to fulfill his mission I am stuck
on the fact that I think Bill Murray has
something in that fake chronopolis that
he needs but it's highly guarded and
every time he tries something happens
they've created something I think when
Janet was in there she's working with
Bill Murray they created something to
make sure that Kane could not get in
there so Kang's like I need to get in
there and he has what I need and that's
why he's like Janet's here you guys are
all here might as well just get you guys
to go in there and get it for me dude
and that fits with the theme that every
Christmas movie is a heist movie oh my
God yes
yeah
I love how every Ant-Man appearance he's
doing a heist every time it's like hey
I'm here it's time to Heist everyone
they just need to do that scene I wonder
if they'll do it in quantumania where
he's like we're gonna go in there and
the plan is here's everybody's job and
they just do the actual job in the
Montage they haven't announced my
gopania for this movie but it would be
great if like they're in the quantum
realm and they're like this freedom
fighter has a plan for us and then it's
Michael Pena but it's not him but he's
just an actor
the drum start the little Bongos
yo imagine if if uh Kang took Michael
Penny instead of Scott and his family
I would have watched that what if
Episode 20 times that would be so funny
we need to save that man we need to
protect him at all costs he's so
important so amazing is it crucial I do
like your idea that Cassie dies
it doesn't make sense because it is
where does her suit come from because
there's no way that like when they get
sucked in at the beginning she already
has a suit it doesn't make sense at that
point and I'm also kind of hooked on the
fact that her suit is like purplish
bluish it's kind of green colors and I'm
wondering if like carrying kills the
Cassie we know but makes our new cast he
has his own daughter to like try and
push just got to do whatever he needs
Scott to do right oh a good old a
classic books
Ah that's mine Cassie
that's a deep cut you don't talk about
run home taxi
I'm always trying to get a Hook
reference in there every time I noticed
every time we do this you do this but no
like I I really like this idea because
like what if like we're looking at a
scenario where Cassie normal Cassie dies
and then Kang pulls a Cassie from the
Multiverse but this is a Cassie that's
already a mutant or has superpowers
and so it's just like oh this is how she
gets Powers we took her from an X-Men
Universe by accident do you know how sad
that would be to be the stat to be the K
the Cassie that died powerless and then
another Cassie that did happen
to be fair I mean like the Cassie that
seeing her in the trailer with like her
suit she's pretty confident she seems
very like yeah you know uh puts it like
she knows what's going on she knows her
[ __ ] like so I I kind of I kind of dig
that theory that's a pretty Rogue theory
that uh you know she comes from a
Multiverse too and that it's not his
Cassie which makes it even more
heartbreaking when they have to go to
their back to their own multiverses and
then he just has a dead dog oh my God
and this is how I like how all the
Avengers are either dying or having
children and he's like well I lost a
child and I'm alive
yeah I mean you're on the money they're
just there has been a lot of like child
stuff lately it's been a very big
through line between like love between
scar Iron Man like Iron Man yeah I like
all this idea of like the kids having
kids passing on your lineage Pat you
know putting this burden on your kids
and that's the thing these movies have
to deal with because like the comic
books kids stay kids for like 20 years
but like in in these movies like they're
aging up so fast and we have to cut
they're almost in real time like if it's
two years between movies it's two years
in in the movies too so yeah like this
idea that uh
if other we're seeing other original MCU
Heroes get children to see one who had a
child lose it would be like a big tonal
shift uh yeah crazy crazy do you guys
think that we'll see Loki in this one
like he'll because right now wherever he
is like Kang's taking over taking over
the TVA and stuff do you think we'll see
him it would have to be like a post
credit right you can't put it in yeah
yeah because Loki season two's coming
out so I think post credits he'll be a
Loki related oh yeah for sure I think
that we'll see Loki at the very end I
was gonna say I'm talking about it on
the break room today how
um I think I think a lot of people think
this across the board is that he who
remains sent his variant to the quantum
realm and so I think that Kang is like
I'm gonna [ __ ] up the TVA as soon as I
get out this king is like
was like his goal is like I'm getting
out to conquer don't get me wrong but
first i'm beating my brother my own ass
and then he's gonna find out that so
much [ __ ] happened it would make sense
though for Loki to like talk to Scott at
the end of this movie and be like hey
this guy I know we haven't really
interacted much you probably don't know
much about me out of the fact that I'm
uh interdimensional terrorist but uh
just just I would like to get a few
notes on what you ran into down there
thanks so much I mean like if you think
about it like if Kang gets you know
King's definitely gonna get released
into the Multiverse by the end of this
movie and like we need the person that
knows King the best and Loki's the
biggest K expert right now
um in the Multiverse so like you need
Loki like I I'm excited at the at the um
possibility that we might see Loki as
like an Avenger in a future movie just
be like hey guys you need me a bigger
twist would be not Loki showing up to
talk to Scott but like ravona rensslayer
is showing up to talk to Scott to be
like where's my man
where's the sexy
please
I want the meanest one but no I oh my
goodness I like this idea I mean of
Cassie dying I mean it's very sad it's
very sad to see Cats because I love
little Cassie little Cassie is my Cassie
I I mean I'm sure Katherine Newton is
going to do a great job but little
Cassie I miss her I hope we see a little
for a little bit in this movie so Scott
can say goodbye to his his daughter
that'd be really nice but um I like this
idea of the implications of Cassie dying
and like pushing Scott to the edge and
working with this madman because like
this I feel like it's the one of the few
reasons or um explanations why he would
even work with someone as crazy as gang
but yeah yeah no I like this Theory I'm
gonna give it a double rogus myself well
what do you guys think double rumpus
double robots this is already a double I
don't give a [ __ ] what you think
it's a burn vote I guess but I will give
it a roguez
because I want this Cassie dead yeah
you need to kill more kids kill the
children yeah CMC KMC I don't know how
to spell
okay
like I'm sure she's great but like
remember the trailer when she's like
she's yelling dad she's like Dad like I
feel like there wasn't as much emotion
in that so maybe this is a bearing just
be like you know this isn't my dad I
genuinely empty I thought about that I
was like that's not bad acting I think
this character does not give two craps
about this [ __ ] about this man he was
gone he's like oh Dad 616 dad I was like
I'd be crying snot going Dad she went
dead
oh wow is that your father I guess is
that your dad a real casual dab what do
you think about oh I gave him a double
roguez I thought you came out of the
gate and I'm like wow she's like
swinging and it's gone hey it's gone
baby this is like a real a double roguez
for sure like did not see that one
coming and then the more we talked about
I'm like that kid's dead
she is the ultra Rogue of us all as long
as it's titled Rogue Theory and not
Jessica this has to be realistic Theory
then
this is true yeah yeah well this was
great guys I like this this conversation
I cannot wait for this freaking movie so
much but there's another big thing that
is out right now it's on HBO Max it's
called The Last of Us
um it's time for our real question by
the way I forgot to turn this to the
back oh I like that little preview
though that was hot thanks but with the
Last of Us premiering on HBO this
weekend this could be a big moment for
video games being turned into television
series so what is your wrongest pitch
for a series based on any video game
throughout history it could be anything
could be [ __ ] pong for all we know no
someone else goes first I forgot oh my
God oh my God I was I was thinking about
what my favorite game was like what my
favorite game was and um I would just I
genuinely think this would be a great
idea for a show so someone please pick
it up uh did you guys
could you imagine as a game just a bunch
of like young kids like teens or
ruthless teens just graffiti painting
everything and running away from the
cops running away from everything but
just outwardly just an artist folks just
like getting really deep into that I
would watch that show and you could uh
you can hide in it I think you stay
Baseline Jet Set Radio but do what they
did for like the Joker like go deep with
it be like who are these kids
backstories
just like post-apocalyptic and these are
like kids that are just like this is the
earliest Ancient Art we know and we're
gonna keep doing it it's like graffiti
or something I will take it but Jet Set
Radio was my [ __ ] so
I think there's a is there an anime of
it there might be an anime too which
would be freaking that was my favorite
video
of that would be like unreal it'd be
super dope I love that idea Jessup radio
is one of those games that is like a
cult classic people don't really talk
about it but like it's it's so amazing
the music was good the art the P the the
clothes the style baby bring it back yes
you know I would love like a like an
ancient spider verse animation style
Fortune set right now
for sure oh my god well what do you guys
think it's not fair but I'm gonna say I
have two Go For It Go Rogue one's like a
serious one and one's like that's you
know for a little goofy but one the
serious why I think ghost of sushima
would be an amazing HBO show uh it's
already such an incredible narrative I
think it would really fit along the
lines with something like the last of us
but it's different you can shoot in that
Kurosawa style uh that story if you guys
have never played that game that story
is uh it's phenomenal it's a great story
and would translate well yeah well
several episodes begin and then the
character dies and that's the end of the
episode and then the next episode is
restarting that same episode again
this time yeah it's only oh you gotta
liberate this cabin in this cab it's not
actually the story it's just all side
quests you know
that's hilarious but I think that one
would translate really really well so
and then the other one I think would be
uh I really just want like like at a
very eccentric a live-action version of
uh NBA Jam from the 90s yes baby Yes
baby it's like it's like
yeah dude like it'd be like it's just
two feet two so it's just like in this
world NBA players are just it's just two
people on the teams that's hilarious and
you get to know the relationships you
know maybe there's a bromance still
cooking and like you know I think that
would be really fun very Slice of Life
sport like sport anime but live action
yo let's get Charles Barkley shut up and
jam a series in this right now oh my God
and it has to be those the NBA Jam
roster so it'd be like Scotty Pippen you
know or something like that
the 90s
that's hilarious I love that so much
that's so funny
my dream my dream game already being
turned into a show so excited for it
twisted metal cannot wait oh yeah
they're doing it live action I'm very
excited about it I talked to one of the
writers about it it sounds like a great
show doing all these crazy stunts sounds
great very excited so that's great
that's already happening my next pitch
we're gonna go back we're gonna go old
school going to Sega Genesis we're
talking about a launch game exclusive to
Sega baby Echo the dolphin hear me out
um
using his powers of sonar to figure out
what's going wrong in the ocean and
stopping it there's no talking ever ever
there's no talking it's a lot of animal
noises it's just like the people who
animated for his dark materials are
animating this one because that they did
a great job
dude yeah no I want a second Pitch
second Pitch make it into a genuine TV
show play it like The Sandlot Backyard
Baseball do it for the YouTube
cereal do it for the kids
backyard bro I've been like campaigning
for a Humongous Entertainment Cinematic
Universe with Backyard Baseball freaking
Spy Fox uh Pajama Sam
I was playing PC games I haven't been
playing PC games since I was in
preschool baby give me that box cereal
but no oh you even do like a PBS hear me
out last pitch sorry PBS style like
drama show like Downton Abbey or
whatever but it's Oregon Trail and it's
like it's for it's full of older ladies
because I know like all the moms love
that kind of stuff so it's like the
Oregon Trails oh yeah like
I love this but I'll have to give the
trophy for the real question to Jessica
for to the amazing Jet Set Radio and
Backyard Baseball like two out of the
cut amazing for both of those so Jessica
you get on trophy for rogue question row
Queen for today claps for Jessica
make those shows if you did the sand lot
like Backyard Baseball it's so easy and
it's just the Sandlot but you involve
women and people more people of color
right that's all it is it's just a sand
lot with it yeah with Pete wheeler
that's it that's basically all it is but
that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory thanks to our amazing guest
Jessica Clemens mad Acevedo and Brandon
Barrick support our Channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch of Rodney
rockstarsmerch.com you can follow me at
mastertonments but you see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] he can follow me rock stars
on all social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on the
YouTube tube.com we'll see you guys next
time we love you guys so much be safe
and goodbye
radio
[Music]